うわぁあぁぁぁぁ
いてて　なになに　痛い　痛いよ　いて　いてて　いて
こんにちは！
はじめしゃちょーです！
今日は！掃除しようと思います！
お気づきだと思うんですけども
床がすごい滑ります
床がすごい滑るんですけど
滑るだけじゃない
今回はそれだけじゃない
最近の動画で僕は部屋を汚し過ぎた
そこのスポンジ
床に散らばる、BB弾
そして大量の梱包材
雨なので洗濯物干せない
床がスリスリする
どういうことだ！
もう嫌　BB弾だらけ
もう...部屋がやばい　まじで！
本当に最近の撮影で
なぜかすごい部屋が汚れることばっかりしちゃって
一般的な家じゃないよ
なんでBB弾散らばってて、すごい滑って（床）
梱包材だらけで、スポンジが固めてあって
るの？
めぇ！　めぇ！
もうちょっとまじでやばい
このままだと僕はもう、人間じゃなくなってしまう
人の住む環境ではないので
ちょっと今日の動画は、とりあえず掃除します。うん
まずできることからやっていこう
掃除も兼ねて今日の動画にする
もう最高
というわけで、まず僕がしようと思ったのは
何が1番スペースとっているかというと
こちら　間違えなく梱包材
梱包材が1番場所を取ってるんで
まずは、梱包材を潰します
で思ったんだけど
梱包材...よく見てください
おっきなプチプチに見えませんか？
よく見るとなんか大きなプチプチだと思ったんすよ
ほら　プチプチも空気が入ってるからさ
てか、プチプチも梱包材だ
よく考えたら超巨大なプチプチだと思ってた
1粒1粒が超でかいプチプチだと思って
ここにすごい数の巨大のプチプチがあるわけよ
（梱包材の破裂音）
これだ
もう部屋がほんとにやばい
部屋がやばいよー！
というわけで、今日の動画は
プチプチを潰します
それだけ
いや多分ね　見てて気持ちい動画になると思うんで
早速巨大プチプチ1000個、ぶっ潰していこうと思います
では、いこう
（梱包材の破裂音）
おえぇぇ！
うお！
（梱包材の破裂音）
うあー！
（耳鳴りの効果音）
あ''
（梱包材の破裂音）
あ！
あ！！
あ！！！
あ！！！！
う’ぅ
（梱包材の破裂音）
うぁ..
うぁ！
（梱包材の破裂音）
あ’’
もうちょい！！！
（梱包材の破裂音）
よっしゃぁ！！
ラスト！
（梱包材と腕が当たる音）
あ...やべ　ミスった
あ.....